Alice back and forth game but finally
you come out on top but I have to ask
you what was this opening preparation
how did you anticipate E4 E5 D4 coming
from Carissa um yeah so I think she
actually played this recently in a
Charlotte super Swiss
um that was a week ago and again I think
the mirror married off so I saw the game
where she played like this queen T4 move
uh so I uh that wasn't in my file so I
had to do like my coach sent me some
lines there some new files yeah so after
um so I like sort of anticipated this
also the G4 line because I know that the
US like women's Olympiad team like plays
this D4 line and I think there were the
game in the Olympia where uh Tata of
abrahamian played G4
um so I was able to like look uh over
the lines there
um and this 1954 I knew this idea before
the game although of course there were
like a lot of other lines I had review
so I didn't review it like
um it too deeply like I missed this 92
move right and this 92 move is not liked
by the engine but definitely poses some
serious practical problems right yeah
because uh here
so I know after C4 there was Queen of
six so I thought after
um after 92 I could try Queenie queen of
six also so like of course it was kind
of annoying for me because I can't do
906 so like C4 yeah
um so queen of six I think Queen H4 was
the only move or I didn't really
consider finish but I was just like
calculating to make sure that queen of
six didn't like immediately lose yeah um
but yeah I guess kunisher was the best
one and then you got into the design
game how did you assess this one
um yeah I I had no idea like how to
address this but I thought um I mean I
thought it was probably objectively
equal although I did think that I could
try to play for something I guess the
engine Synthroid is slightly better what
are the authors love to call oh yeah
Dynamic equality yeah oh yeah I found 93
here and then I wasn't sure what to do I
saw like maybe uh yeah like because if
we're 64 Knight F5 so yes
um I really want to show what to do I
guess even sacrificing the exchanges
even this is fine yeah I have uh three
pounds
um and perhaps this would have been
the way you would have played but this
was the moment that kind of baffled yeah
all of us yeah no I don't I have no idea
what I was doing here like I knew I had
to be better especially after I got like
92 and
um maybe I should have just like done
Rook takes who was playing for a win in
this I feel like she would claim for the
win because she always had this option
of like after Bishop D4 F3
um she can always like repeat I guess
like if she wants like work she works C7
and then uh yeah I'd like work back but
I don't think she wanted to draw so she
went for this before but I thought here
um I mean I thought it should still be
okay for me because at the very least I
can there are some lines that I was
calculating that I can sacrifice my
Workforce tonight in the bee Pond
um and I think perhaps this one was one
of them right at this point when she had
Knight to F6 you already sacrificed
these yeah I was pretty happy here like
I was going to do reptix F6 in the
nursery C5 and I thought it should
probably be a draw but I can still try
to put because I have the extra Pawn
there's still some players left
absolutely
yeah but she played no T3 and then I was
like oh wait I have this idea of rookie
three and then I'm certainly in Rook F2
and rookie one so I was so then I
thought that I should probably be
winning here do you think that this is
what she missed yeah I think though I
think maybe she had like calculated some
lines here with like B7
yeah something like that I mean 92 but
then she probably realized that I can
like take on E2 and then I think
um I think I was putting the F work in
number 63 rupees oh no Rook C3 Rook B2
and then I get the two connected two
bombs yes very nice very nice
take
yeah that should be winning it should be
waiting absolutely
nicely calculated yeah and uh after that
I think it was quite clinical from
Europe takes C6 get the two points extra
and just win that one yeah Alice is this
the first time you uh win against
Carissa yeah
um this is the first time I think I
activated over the board so it was
something like really new for me and I
would like going into the theme I
thought a draw would be fine
um but I definitely wasn't expecting to
win and it was just like really great to
be able to win against such a strong
player and this definitely has helped of
course like with my tournaments while
I'm sure you're welcoming this uh
surprise let's say yeah guys any
questions for our leader in the junior
girls our congratulations to be sure
Alice I just had a quick question for me
uh the move B3 B4 was a surprise I
thought it was a mistake from uh Carissa
and I was actually curious just to get
your opinion uh what what did you think
would be the result after Knight E4 did
you oh yeah the most obvious move I
thought yeah I thought 84 with
annoying but I'm not sure what I was
planning to do here I think like
um
F2 probably white is white is pushing
for a win probably what was my feeling
as well that white would be better if
you played yeah so I think also I need
to play
I think I was calculating like Rook E2
Rook E2 okay
and if like on 1965 F2
uh other like
um
I mean I said I still thought like this
would be like slightly worse foreign
for
aha
I'm sorry some Chaos on the board going
on yeah like I'm not sure if like Rick
Rook C8 uh then Rick f8 repeat right so
I mean it's like white always has a draw
in her yeah well it always has to draw
where she wanted yeah with versus Rook
C7 okay so just 94 was it was a part of
your calculations as well yeah or Alice
you've got two very big games to uh
still play keep your mind on the
tournament and our congratulations for a
very very big win today thank you
absolutely what a great performance